Syrians make up the largest number of
refugees in the world the world though
hasn't been too welcoming to them ironic
when you look at Syria's history with
other refugees thousands of sick Asians
fleeing a Russian invasion made new
homes in Syria
Armenians fleeing mass killings in
Turkey resettled in Syria in large
numbers and in 1948 and 1967
Palestinians escaping Israeli wars and
occupation crossed into Syria Syria has
also taken in refugees fleeing war in
various other countries more recently
when the u.s. invaded Iraq thousands of
Iraqis found refuge across the border
three years later
Syrians welcomed Lebanese escaping the
war with Israel can the world learn
something from Syria's hospitality
[Music]